les enfants on a parlé de ce qui est
souvent considérée comme la forme ultime
des sciences à savoir les tests
randomisée en double aveugle avec roger
d'hypothèses part prévalu ce que je
viens de dire est pour vous du charabia
je vous invite vivement à aller voir ou
revoir les deux vidéos précédentes on a
aussi vu en quoi ces approches étaient
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
mieux que des approches purement
intuitive notamment étant donné les
inévitables facteurs de confusion et les
omniprésentes fluctuations statistiques
si les sciences sont devenus beaucoup
plus fiable qu'avant c'est un très très
très grande partie grâce aux expériences
randomisée et aux statistiques partait
value mais le fait que ces méthodes
marche mieux que nos cerveaux de
primates ne signifie pas qu'elles sont
parfaites en fait aujourd'hui on va voir
en quoi ces standards ultime de la
science d'aujourd'hui sont en fait très
loin d'être pleinement satisfaisant et
pourquoi il est temps de sérieusement
remettre en question ce qui est souvent
dit de la méthode scientifique
voici cinq arguments contre la science
par p vaio
travers numéro un toute hypothèse serait
sera rejeté une infinité de fois
on l'a vu la dernière fois avec un seuil
à 1 % une hypothèse vrai à une
probabilité de 1% d'être rejeté par la
méthode scientifique par p value et à
prioris apparaître un taux d'erreur
acceptable
cependant dit aussi des sciences
qu'elles sont censées tester une
hypothèse encore et encore et on dit
aussi souvent que si une hypothèse n'a
pas été rejetée par un test par p value
c'est peut-être parce que tu est manquée
de ce qu'on appelle la puissance
statistique
alors je ne veux pas rentrer dans les
détails mais il est important de noter
que si on teste une hypothèse devrait
encore et encore vu qu'à chaque fois
elle à 99% de chances de survivre aux
tests elle aura une probabilité 99%
puissant celle de survivre à un test
indépendant
or une telle probabilité d croît
exponentiellement vite vers zéro après
69 expérience l'hypothèse aura une
probabilité de 50% de survivre et après
459 expérience la probabilité de survie
sera de seulement 1% et bien sûr à
l'infini cette probabilité tend vers
zéro
alors vous pourriez rétorqué qui semble
idiot de répéter encore et encore la
même expérience des centaines de fois
oui en effet sauf qu'en pratique il ya
parfois des centaines de groupes de
recherche différents qui bossent sur le
même sujet ce qui fait vite des
centaines d'expérience mais surtout
chaque groupe de recherche pourrait
vouloir tester une conséquence
différente de la théorie pourvu que
quelques centaines de conséquence de la
théorie sont testés il faut s'attendre à
au moins un rejet voire potentiellement
des dizaines de rejet de théories vrai
et en particulier à l'infini la méthode
scientifique par p va lui garantit que
toute hypothèse vrai finira par être
rejetée pire encore elle sera rejetée
une infinité de fois voilà une propriété
épistémologique qui semble pas
franchement désirable
travers numéro 2 l'invalidité des arrêts
prématurés
une variante que subtile de ce phénomène
et le fait de suivre la valeur de la
paix valu au fur et à mesure que les
données s'accumulent
et de conclure dès que la paix value
passe sous le seuil de 1%
ça peut paraître innocent mais en
choisissant de conclure tech on peut
conclure on biaise complètement la
validité de la paix value d'une certaine
manière on crée un biais de sélection
qui augmente fortement la probabilité de
rejeter une hypothèse vrai même avec un
seuil à 1 %
le fait de conclure dès que possible
fait passer la probabilité de rejet
d'une hypothèse vrai de 1 % à 20 %
après quelques milliers de données et
bien sûr le phénomène est bien plus
catastrophiques avec des seuils à 5 ou
10% et le gros problème c'est que si on
publie ensuite un article sans préciser
qu'on a choisi le moment d'arrêter la
collecte de données parce qu'on avait
une paix value publiable alors personne
ne pourra se douter de rien les auteurs
pourront écrire nous avons appliqué la
méthode par p value avec mes seins sans
donner sans avoir menti et peut être
même sans se rendre compte du billet
dans leur analyse
l'article semblera alors parfaitement
être aux standards de la méthode
scientifique par p value pour éviter le
biais de sélection du moment d'arrêter
l'étude statistique
les statisticiens exigé souvent des
auteurs des études qu'il fixe a priori
la taille de l'échantillon d'études et
qu'ils interdisent ensuite tout arrêt
prématuré de l'étude
cependant on peut alors légitimement se
demander si cette décision est éthique
par exemple quand j'ai eu la shoah
tester sa capacité à implanter des faux
souvenirs chez ces sujets les résultats
préalable était si impressionnant que
pour protéger les sujets l'étude a dû
être arrêtée prématurément
techniquement donc l'étude du jus à
chaud ne réponde a du coup plus hauts
standards des statistiques fréquentes
east et pourtant le cas du jus la chaux
est encore relativement éthiquement
acceptable le cas des groupes de
contrôle de maladies graves semble par
exemple nettement plus problématique
oui oui ça va vous savez la wii qui
caractérise pour mieux répondre aux
considérations éthiques sur les torts
potentiellement causer aux patients que
ce soit par le choix de leur administrer
un traitement potentiellement nuisibles
ou par celui de ne pas leur administrer
un traitement potentiellement salvateur
d'autres statisticiens se sont mis à
considérer des cadres différents pour
mesurer les effets des traitements et
surtout pour décider si un traitement
devrait être administré ou non par
exemple il ya le cadre du multi armes de
ben 10
ce cadre invite à ignorer la question de
l'existence d'un effet statistiquement
significatifs et de la remplacer par la
question de la prise de décisions
rapidement quasi optimales de traitement
ou non et ce n'est sans doute pas plus
mal car au final l'objectif est bien
souvent le bien des patients
pas de déterminer si le traitement à un
effet statistiquement significatifs
travers numéro 3 bien des publications
on a déjà un peu parlé et on en
reparlera plus longuement une prochaine
fois
mais l'une des raisons importantes pour
lesquelles la paix value semble
problématique dans le contexte actuel de
la recherche
c'est le fait que comme nous sommes
constamment inondés d'informations il
nous est impossible de tout lire pour
aider tout le monde à mieux parcourir
l'ensemble des résultats des sciences
les scientifiques ou donc mise en place
des journaux de publication des
résultats scientifiques ces journaux
publient des articles qui communique les
résultats importants des études
scientifiques et pour faire le tri ces
journaux sont cotées selon leur impact
factor chaque article soumis à ces
journaux est relu par des pairs qui
valide ou non la qualité informationnel
de l'article avec une intransigeance
d'autant plus grande que le journal a un
grand impact factor voilà qui du coup
cause inévitablement un biais de
publications
en effet les résultats les plus relayer
et les plus lus par les scientifiques
seront alors nécessairement des
résultats qui ont été validées par les
journaux scientifiques et est important
de noter que ce bien est globalement
désirable c'est a priori un biais en
faveur des informations de qualité
cependant malheureusement ce biais est
aussi très imparfait il favorise
certains résultats plutôt que d'autres
et est donc une représentation biaisée
de l'ensemble des études scientifiques
typiquement ce biais va fortement
favorisé les résultats dit
statistiquement significatif c'est à
dire les rougets d'hypothèses par la
méthode scientifique par p valu aux
dépens des résultats non statistiquement
significatif mais potentiellement aux
aussi utile typiquement les résultats
statistiquement significatifs vont
indiquer l'existence d'un effet un
traitement mais il peut être aussi utile
de signaler l'absence d'effet un
traitement mais ce n'est pas tout parce
que les journaux scientifiques vont
vouloir publier des articles qui seront
cités par la suite et parce que les
résultats spectaculaires ou plus de
chances d'être citée par la suite ils
vont privilégier la publication de tels
résultats
or ces résultats ont aussi une plus
grande probabilité d'être de faux
positifs mais ça on en parlera bien plus
longuement une prochaine fois
travers numéro 4
le p hacking
alors c'est tout les scientifiques
étaient des bisounours qui appliquaient
méticuleusement la méthode scientifique
comme on l'a vu il y aurait déjà pas mal
de problèmes sauf que en pratique les
scientifiques ne sont pas entièrement
des bisounours ou du moins à cause de
l'explosion du nombre de doctorants et
de la diminution des budgets de la
recherche les scientifiques sont dans
une compétition telle qu'un chercheur
bisounours aura bien du mal à survivre à
hisser le jeu pas les joueurs tout cela
est mise en exergue par la formule
publish or perish et malheureusement
pour la plupart des doctorants
ce sera parish ses doctorants ont beau
être la crème de la crème
ils sont en compétition avec d'autres
doctorants qui eux aussi sont la crème
de la crème
et dans ce contexte les incentives a
publié son énorme
or pour publier surtout dans le cadre de
la méthode scientifique par p value il
faut des résultats spectaculaires qui
rejette une hypothèse qui paraissait
pourtant vrai voilà qui a conduit
certains à employer consciemment ou non
des stratégies dites de paix hacking
l'idée de ce pea king est incroyablement
simpliste effectué un très grand nombre
d'expériences et oui si on suppose un
seuil à 1 %
on sait que les hypothèses vrai ont une
probabilité de 1% d'être rejeté par la
méthode scientifique part prévalu
du coup il suffit d'effectuer environ
100 tests d'hypothèses très crédible
pour en avoir une qui sera un rejet
spectaculaire d'une hypothèse très
crédible le problème bien sûr c'est
qu'en ne publiant que ce rejet
spectaculaire la publication aura l'air
d'être parfaitement aux standards de la
paix value elle semblera parfaitement
scientifiquement valide
elles se sont toutes pour les auteurs
même de publications qui ont très bien
pu ne pas s'être rendu compte qu'ils
avaient déployé là une stratégie de paix
hacking oui parce que là j'ai parlé d'un
seuil à 1 %
mais en pratique c'est souvent davantage
un seuil à 5% qui est utilisé auquel cas
il suffit d'avoir tenté 20 expérience
seulement orvin petite expérience s'est
pas beaucoup on peut noter que les
initiatives de paix hacking sont
toutefois pas spécifique à la paix value
il s'agit d'un cas particulier d'un
phénomène plus général appelait la loi
de good rares dont on a déjà parlé dans
l'épisode 37 de la série sur
intelligence artificielle
cette loi dit qu'un manque une mesure
correspondent exactement à ce que l'on
cherche à maximiser dès qu'une mesure
devient un objectif
elle cesse d'être une bonne mesure or
dans un climat publish or perish tous
critères de publication un parfait de
viendra inéluctablement 1
objectif retrouve ainsi le même problème
pour d'autres métriques utilisé dans
d'autres domaines pour être publiés par
exemple en machine learning
on a souvent des problèmes bien définis
avec un score de performance des
algorithmes pour être publié c'est
souvent très utile de battre le meilleur
score jusque là ce qu'on appelle parfois
devenir l'état de l'art sauf que la
reproductibilité de ces expériences est
en fait très questionnable
déjà parce qu effectué l'expérience
nécessite parfois des puissances de
calcul et donc des dépenses énergétiques
faramineuse mais aussi parce que les
algorithmes sont souvent randomisée et
ne donne donc pas le même résultat d'une
itération à l'autre en fait à bien y
réfléchir cette rando mise à sion et
même utile pour espérer battre le
meilleur score exactement comme elle
l'est pour avoir parfois une plus-value
publiables pour des hypothèses vrai
travers numéro 5 malléabilité
enfin le cinquième et dernier travers
que je vais mentionné aujourd'hui et la
malléabilité de la méthode scientifique
parp évalue alors qu'est ce que
j'entends par malléabilité et bien
souvenez vous que j'ai décrit les
statistiques comme une boîte à outils
pour chaque nouveau problème auquel il
est confronté le statisticien va alors
regarder le problème et choisir un outil
à utiliser pour faire parler les données
le truc c'est que si ça ne marche pas
par exemple s'il n'obtient pas une paix
value publiable alors il peut piocher un
autre outil de sa boîte à outils comme
par exemple rajouter un hypothétique
facteurs de confusion et voir s'il
obtient alors une période où publiable
et puis il pourra ensuite piocher un
autre outil encore et ainsi de suite
et ce faisant il multiplie ainsi le
nombre de tests qui va effectuer et donc
la probabilité d'obtenir une paix value
publiables par exemple imaginons que
l'on soit une entreprise pharmaceutique
et qu'on cherche a validé la vente d'un
médicament
pour cela il nous faut montrer que ce
médicament a un effet on effectue alors
des tests cliniques randomisées en
double aveugle et là pas de bol notre
médicament ne semble pas faire mieux
qu'un placebo ou du moins la paix value
nette alors pas publiable le truc c'est
que vous pouvez maintenant poser
d'autres questions avec le même jeu de
données peut être que le médicament a un
effet pour les plus de 40 ans par
exemple ou peut-être juste sur les
femmes
ou peut-être juste sur une personne en
surpoids et petit à petit à force de
répéter les questions comme la paix
value n'est pas parfaite
vous finirez bien par tomber sur une
question dont la paix value est
publiable en pratique selon le
philosophe jacob staking à ce genre de
pratique combiné aux très nombreux
autres travers de paix value dans les
tests cliniques a conduit à la mise en
circulation d'un très grand nombre de
médicaments qui n'ont fait aucun effet
alors là j'ai pris un exemple où la
malléabilité est quand même assez
évidente
cependant en pratique quand on considère
des données plus sophistiqué qui ne sont
pas issus de tests randomisée en double
aveugle
la boîte à outils statistiques est
tellement énorme que le statisticien
lui-même ne seront peut-être pas compte
de la liberté dont ils disposent et du
bien est inconsciente de raisonnement
motivé que cela lui permet par exemple
en 2017 mêmes données de football ont
été fournies à 29 équipes de recherche
différentes
on leur a demandé d'effectuer un test
statistique pour savoir si les arbitres
étaient racistes et en particulier ne
donnaient pas plus facilement des
cartons rouges un des joueurs de couleur
de peau noire
voici les conclusions des 29 équipes de
recherche de façon stupéfiante les
résultats a l'air de aucun effet
statistiquement significatifs à trois
fois plus probable de données
thon rouge est un joueur noir cas un
blanc imaginez maintenant que les
journaux ne public que les résultats
spectaculaires on obtiendrait alors
uniquement de résultats publiés
concordants sur l'existence d'un racisme
très prononcé des arbitres de football
il ne serait pas faute de publier en
gros titre de tf1 que deux études
indépendantes montrent que les arbitres
sont trois fois plus sévère avec les
noirs qu'avec les blancs il insiste en
particulier sur le fait que le 29
équipes de recherche ici n'était ni
frauduleuse ni incompétente
il s'agissait de statisticiens très
compétent et très motivé a vraiment
répondre à la question qu'il aurait été
posée le truc c'est que la méthode
scientifique qu'ils utilisaient tout
simplement pas objectives notamment
parce qu'elle part entièrement défini
elle permet à quiconque les de mettre sa
petite touche personnelle entend ainsi
subjective toute analyse des données
elle est malléable des leurs à cause du
biais de publications il faut s'attendre
à la publication de résultats très
divergents de l'analyse d'un
statisticien médian
bref c'est donc j'espère vous avoir con
todd scientifique par p value ce
standard ultime le plus répandu des
sciences n'est absolument pas parfait ce
standard est même extrêmement
problématique et conduit à des
publications de résultats très biaisée
par rapport à l'ensemble des
observations scientifiques
la méthode scientifique par p value
conduit à de sacrés travers ce qui
explique les très nombreux articles de
statisticiens qui la dénonce alors bien
sûr ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut
enlever les statistiques de la méthode
scientifique au contraire tout ceci
montre que même avec des statistiques
établies par des grands mathématiciens
il persiste des billets majeur dans
l'analyse des données scientifiques
laissant ses statistiques
c'est via serait sans doute bien pire
encore en fait sans statistiques il n'ya
tout simplement pas de méthode
scientifique
le truc c'est que bien analyser des
données statistiques c'est avant tout
extrêmement difficile si difficile que
même les mathématiciens s'engueule
parfois avec virulence sur ce sujet et
spoiler alert
il est extrêmement difficile d'avoir des
raisonnements purement bayésiens en
pratique notamment dès lors que les
données et les théories sont ultra
complexes à décrire et à confronter et
surtout lorsqu'on prend également en
compte le fait que les puissances de
calcul de nos machines et les facultés
cognitives de nous autres humains sont
très limités faire de la bonne science
c'est compliqué néanmoins il me
semblerait extrêmement problématique de
ne pas au moins sérieusement cherché à
faire mieux que ce qui est fait
aujourd'hui notamment d'un point de vue
méthodologique
en fait ça m'exaspère même au plus haut
point d'entendre parfois certains dire
que la méthode scientifique
d'aujourd'hui est la moins pire des
méthodes
ça me semble être une absence
d'autocritique un excès de confiance et
un raisonnement motivé indigne
d'intellectuels qui prétendent vouloir
connaître au mieux du monde qui les
entoure d'autant qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai
en fait mentionner qu'une partie des
travers de la méthode scientifique
en fait je n'ai même pas mentionné les
travers que je trouve les plus graves
oui car pour tout vous dire à la base je
comptais faire un top 10 des travers de
la méthode scientifique par p value mais
comme il ya juste trop de choses à dire
je vais laisser cinq autres énormes
travers de la méthode scientifique par p
value pour la prochaine fois dernière
fois j'avais parlé de l'ap évaluer
notamment je l'avais introduit dans le
cadre d'une distribution gaussienne plus
ou moins gaussienne j'avais un petit peu
insisté sur le fait que certains des
raisonnements que j'avais fait était
spécifique à une distribution gaussienne
qu'on a cherché à tester et or l hérault
a du coup de monde
et à juste titre de ce qu'on pouvait
faire lorsque la distribution n'était
pas à gaussienne mais en fait la notion
de paix value ne dépend pas de la
gaussienne c'est juste certains aspects
que j'ai printanière faut notamment les
histoires de 5,6 demain qui
correspondent vraiment en tout cas à la
base à la notion de social
mais la notion de paix valent ou plus
rarement s'applique à toutes sortes de
distribution qui concerne nous données
numériques observé encore une fois la
paix value c'est la probabilité des
données pire que la donne et qui a été
observé et ça on peut la définir pour
toutes sortes de distribution et en
pratique typiquement celle utilisée pour
différentes distributions pour
différents tests statistiques utilisées
en pratique cependant il est intéressant
de noter que pour que ça soit
relativement bien défini on a tendance
quand même à ceux ramenés à la
distribution une loi de distribution
concernant une donnée numérique de
dimensions 1
or bien souvent en pratiquant et
commence à faire beaucoup plus de mesure
et du coup avoir des espaces de plus
grande dimension et du coup il est
intéressant de se poser des questions
sur des tests statistiques de plus
grande dimension
auquel cas la paix value ne s'applique
pas toujours très bien en tout cas la
paix value de fischer parce qu'après
pour des zones est plus général il reste
possible de définir des tests sismiques
notamment ceux de neyman et personnes
dont on reparlera sans doute une
prochaine fois
mais en gros ça a à voir avec ce qu'on
appelle le rapport de vraisemblance où
le facteur de bellissen cdc m'anime et
tout ça on en parle à une prochaine fois
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
et que vous resterez là pour le prochain
nous donnerait vraiment les cinq
arguments qui me semblent les plus
importants contre la méthode
scientifique parts évaluer si vous avez
aimé cet épisode conseil d'ajka le
commentaire de partager pour services de
données pour que les futurs épisodes
merci un petit peur pour leurs dons et
j'espère que vous serez là la prochaine
fois
la classe